I'm above this moment I'm floating all
over the place right now my heart is me
I had to double-check the envelope to
make sure it was incredible I'm
speechless speechless only et was
backstage at the 2020 Grammys on Sunday
and we caught up with some of the
biggest stars of the night tonight as
for Kobe et was with Elizabeth a
ceremony by dedicating the night to Kobe
Bryant who died in a helicopter crash
earlier in the day Kobe Kobe and his
family his daughter the truth hurts
singer was nominated for eight Grammys
and took home three wins oh yeah
and she dropped her Grammy how is this
moment let me come back to it I'm above
this moment I'm floating all over the
place right now
I can't tell you I'll tell you tomorrow
I feel really humbled and honored and
I'm sure what would you tell that girl
who was struggling and trying to find
her way a few years ago and what would
you tell her about this moment being on
the Grammy stage but she would believe
in herself and that's all that matters
and what happen when you drop it girl I
tripped
et also chatted with Billy Eilish who
won five yeah freaking 5 Grammys
including album song new artist record
and Pop Vocal album damn girl just
turned into your night I guess
I'm dying man I don't know beyond your
wildest dreams this is like a dream oh
my god this is my brother he's the boy
how do you how do you take in this
moment oh you don't know a couple years
from now we'll be like remember that one
time I'm speechless speechless after
usher brought down the house with a
tribute to Prince he dished about what
it meant to him to honor the music icon
his spirit is all over this place and
it's a real heavy time for the world
right now we just wanted to shine some
light and et caught up with Gwen Stefani
and Blake Shelton right after they had
us all up in our fields performing their
song nobody but you
[Music]
whoo look at this that's not just from
years of drinking that's from performing
with Gwen Stefani on the Grammys
something oh yeah yes sir it was an
incredible thing I'm so grateful to be
here
bebe Rexha was still coming down from
presenting the award for best country
duo/group Performance alongside Shania
Twain I just presented with Shania Twain
like what the dan + Shay won that award
for their song speechless and let's just
say they weren't so speechless backstage
all freaking out I don't know I don't
even know where I am right now to be
honestly that blacked out like an hour
ago yeah woke up on stage this is an
absolute honor for us I mean this is
just absolutely incredible
I really cannot my heartis be I had to
double check the envelope to make sure
I'm hanging out of this for dear life
man but of course the one thing weighing
on everyone's mind was Kobe it was
painful it's painful right now it's
still painful and we lost a beloved
beloved hero to all of us the person who
is like a true example of brilliance and
excellence I think that the energy that
he always brought and that fighting
spirit and that that beautiful uplifting
way you know is what brought us through
tonight and I felt like he was just in
all of our hearts and spirits and that's
what made it feel good Alicia Keys
opened the show by bringing boys two men
on stage to help her pay tribute to the
late a fleet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what was it like going out there knowing
that you're inside the building there
was Kobe's home I mean it's it's an
honor as well as the tragedy you know to
know that he used to you know come back
and forth to the games and you know that
he won't be here any longer his spirit
is still gonna dwell within these
buildings and without doubt in this
building it's just gonna be one of those
things that he's going to be remembered
as one of the greatest that ever did it
Billy Ray Cyrus and lil nas acts honored
Kobe during their performance of Old
Town Road house that performance you had
the Kobe Jersey out there saw paying
tribute you know rest in peace to Kobe
we definitely wanted to do something cuz
you know it's unfortunate you know that
this happened on this day and while
we're at this place
and um yeah you know we love Kobe you
know we all huddled and prayed before we
came out on a stage and we all pray for
Kobe and his family I felt like there
was a very kind and sweet spirit in the
house tonight and again tip of the hat
to mr. Kobe Bryant and what he's man I
don't know if you noticed I even put a
little special Kobe on my guitar they
just happen to have a silver sharpie in
there and you know what Kobe in here
well that's it for today
make sure to stick with ET for all the
latest in music until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]